IT'S TIME FOR SLEDDING INTO YOUR
DMS.
SLEDDING INTO YOUR DMS.
(CHEERING AND APPLAUSE)
SANTA NOW HAS THREE LISTS TO ADD
YOUR NAME TO: NAUGHTY, NICE, AND
CRAIGS.
ACCORDING TO SALON.COM, THE WEB
SITE'S CASUAL ENCOUNTERS SECTION
IS STUFFED WITH SANTA FETISHISTS
LOOKING TO HAVE FREAKY ELF SEX
AND MAKE BAD CHRISTMAS PUNS
WHILE THEY DO IT.
LIKE THIS SUBTLE SINTERKLAAS
RIGHT HERE.
"MARRIED SANTA HAS HAD A ROCK
HARD CANDY CANE ALL DAY AND MY
CHESTNUTS ARE SO FILLED WITH
CREAM THAT THEY ARE ACHING."
OKAY, LISTEN HERE, CLAUS
BANGERS, MAKING BAD CHRISTMAS
PUNS ABOUT HAVING SEX WITH, UH,
SANTA IS OUR JOB.
SO, COMEDIANS, I WOULD LIKE YOU
TO COME UP WITH AS MANY DMS FROM
SANTA AS YOU CAN.
60 SECONDS. AND GO.
(BELL DINGS)
YES, DREW.
>> UH, MORNING, SEXY. YOU UP?
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
BLAINE.
>> UH, SORRY, THAT PICTURE WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE FOR MRS. CLAUS.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
MARGARET.
>> YO, HOW TIGHT THAT CHIMNEY?
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
BLAINE.
>> UH, RUDOLPH DRUNK. SEND HELP.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
DREW.
>> UH, RUDOLPH HAS A RED ASS
NOW, TOO.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
WELL, YEAH, 'CAUSE...
(BELL DINGS)
...THAT'S WHAT YOU GET FOR BEING
THE LEAD REINDEER!
>> YEAH.
>> HARDWICK: MARGARET.
>> WHERE MY HO, HO, HOS AT?
>> HARDWICK: YEAH, POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
DREW CAREY.
>> I WANT TO "SLEIGH" THAT ASS.
>> HARDWICK: YEAH, POINTS.
YEAH.
(BELL DINGS)
MARGARET.
>> UM, DO YOU WANT ME TO LEAVE A
LUMP OF COAL ON YOUR CHEST?
(GROANING)
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.